[Musica]
buongiorno ragazzi miei allora io volevo
dirvi che sono infatti quasi 5 mila
iscritti
sa cosa mi sta stupendo spumeggiante
volevo dirvi molto simpatica ho scoperto
che esiste cioè me l'avete detto voi in
realtà sui direct anche esiste la
wayback machine che questa roba che se
tu scrivi sito che vuoi
lui ti trova le versioni di quel sito
prima come era prima e bellissimo quindi
posso letteralmente vedere il mio canale
agli inizi come era fighissima sta roba
vj fifa licei sono io e prevedere se
esperimento maniero che rischio to check
the fa vj's channel in the back of the
tempo sacco di tempo per il broswer
history e bellissima star o poi beck ma
ci stava di usare la macchina del tempo
il caffè doctor who e lento come la
morte però è realistico perché di
internet ai tempi era veramente lento o
che bello abbiamo dal 2018 17 2 16 2013
allora addirittura pischetti il giorno
che figata affacciamo 2013 quando appena
aperte al mio canale vevo da pochissimo
ap e non ci sono tutti i giorni ma solo
quelli contrassegnati ok 17 gennaio il
primo archivio del mio canale vediamo un
po che esce cuore e lento come la morte
però doveva essere una figata cosa sto
vedendo era così il mio canale 3 mila
iscritti era il 17 gennaio del 2013
tremila iscritti ma che figata dove
comunque il mio background era
bellissimo era uno dei primi e quindi
c'era il vecchio layout di youtube per
ora veramente figo una volta alberi
background di youtube era veramente figo
perché c'è potevi mettere potete
personalizzarla perché come volevi no
allora mi hanno fatto fuori background
ero ancora immagini ma avevo pensato i
57.000 views avevo per toccare da un
mese in totale avevo fatto 57.000 views
il video di oggi in 3 ore ne ha fatte
quasi 200 non mi sto contando era uscito
il più spaventoso di sempre slang quante
volte ho usato sto titolo da quando
faccio video sempre badon che vide erano
riusciti ma cos'è ap niente io in un
giorno avanti li facevano 1500 views da
veri che i files che penso tra vigilia
prove sa tanto che si erano i canali
consigliati che consigliamo jolly fish
games brothers stormi jecfa vario
videogiochi logicamente gmail del gaming
che la mia primo canale che ti casa tra
biglietto io ho scelto a centrare un
altro giorno facciamo 5 febbraio il 5
febbraio avevo 5.313 iscritti quindi
avevo praticamente erano quasi
raddoppiato i miei scritti in un mese e
facevo un po più ti facevano il doppio
del riposo ovviamente issimo che bella
copertina che ebbe la ritagliata da ge
bravo fa vj bravissimo che classe come
te li meriti iscritti come so anche più
di panelli fa vj a proves fa già stavo
crescendo però che figata che c'è un
fatto questa roba
ora esce a febbraio 2013 facciamo aprile
2014 quindi passa completamente un anno
2013 al 2014 by avesse praticamente un
annetto cioè la checa che change minchia
596 mila iscritti nel 2008 più o meno
siamo a aprì il no marzo a marzo 600 gli
iscritti andava ancora a scuola era
l'ultimo anno scolastico
c'è la frank matano che faceva il
gameplay subito e avevo quello che era
il background di tipo già un annetto fa
poi da un po i 60 un povero cambiato
figo quando quattro giorni senza fare
video come da over grotto dio mio over
grotte poi vado che anche tempi e
momenti epici video che stava quasi
fatto un milione di questo sarà il primo
video che poi raggiunto il milione di
visualizzazioni fighissimo fastforward
andiamo nel 2015
micky appena fatto due milioni di
iscritti che sta abbiamo fatto un salto
allucinante 9 momenti epici di
videogames 7 ha raggiunto quasi 10
milioni di views va bene quanti casi mio
sassolino
in sette per un attimo ha già questo
video più visto in assoluto no non è
vero
video vi siano assoluta inter finita
questo è uno dei video più visti 12
milioni e il 2 quello di prima che stava
raggiungendo il migliore quanto ha fatto
poi due gocce normale non ero family
friends in una volta però non c'era il
problema della poca lips quindi perfetto
guarda il caffè divise non sembra gli
sembrano noodles zhou i noodles in testa
maledizione potevi spremerli due
cappelle roba allucinante cosa questo
era fa vj a dio
noi iniziamo che goldman facevano pagare
se non averla facciamo pagare
ero molto bravo però no c'è no avevo una
tonalità strana last algia tua è datata
nero meglio prima anche a me mancano
quei tempi ce nel senso la nostalgia il
ricordo di quello che ero cioè a tutti
manca essere piccoli voglio dire era
figo però obiettivamente paragoni un
video di adesso c'è il prosciutto sugli
occhi forte anche prosciutto prosciutto
di quello proprio scholes per la
fiorentina al sugli occhi vediamo gli
altri commenti curiosità quando ancora
fa mi faceva ridere no quando ti piaceva
la merda però fa niente ma vengo a casa
lo sa il freddo a sberle con la carne
surgelata complimenti 8 parolaccia
minuto se togliamo i commi momenti di
musica quelli in cui finalmente thaci
hai una mary parolaccia in 5 secondi
sparati no ho fatto successo uguale
oppure non lo contatta vi prego ditemi
quanti iscritti o adesso solo per capire
a reaction questi erano i tempi in cui
c'erano gli haters non ricordo anche più
cosa cosa dicevano gli hater hanno
capito di essere dei deficienti non sono
spariti dal pianeta
però una volta c'erano il livello più
vecchio di apb scorso mi ricordo quando
l'uomo fatto andiamo nel novembre del
2016 quindi circa un annetto dopo ha
visto da 2 milioni passiamo a 3,24 47 51
a facce luca che si erano decisamente
tanti però era un periodo molto vicino
ad adesso quindi chi o meno mi riconosco
già molto di più rispetto a prima
e infine dopo tutto sto casino
la grafica nuova nuovo youtube sono
proprio contento della ecc anche pietro
a cavolo pietro non c'era
che tempi saprò contento del percorso
che ho fatto perché un canale si evolve
cioè se guardate gli inizi ero proprio
come si dice da te ero molto
professionale per essere agli inizi
perché facevo video con tanti tagli non
andavo a dormire perché per fare sti
video ci mettevo veramente una vita e
mezza però me la cavavo molto bene nel
senso sono sempre stato abbastanza
orgoglioso di quello che ho fatto
certo con il tempo io sono maturato a
livello cioè sono cresciuto non ho più
16 anni come quando ho iniziato a fare
video è stato proprio bello crescere con
voi per capire noi siamo cresciuti
insieme io ero un bambino a 17 anni era
un bambino con dei noodles è stato
proprio bello vedere questa crescita
il giorno dopo giorno degli iscritti
aumentavano una maniera esponenziale e
non ho mai capito il perché di questa
cosa in realtà c'è veramente incredibile
e stato bello per carità è stato è stato
un periodo bellissimo della mia vita
quello da quando iniziato a fare youtube
da youtube in poi non solo per il
successo va beh ma anche perché mi sono
più divertito tanto cioè per me era
arrivato qui oggi gli dica tanto proprio
livello personale proprio perché sono
riuscito a portare una passione farla
diventare il fulcro della mia vita
perché alla fine gira tutto intorno a
quello perché se io vivo da solo e
grazie a questo sia conosciuto tante
persone nella mia vita grazie a questo
so viaggiato grazie a queste grazie a
voi alla fine siamo arrivati fino a qua
quindi non volevo che diventa subito
strappalacrime queste però grazie
ragazzi di mi ha accompagnato in questo
divide viaggio spero di aver fatto un po
parte della vostra infanzia cioè
infanzia adolescente l'infanzia
ci siamo divertiti tutti ma non è finita
qui è manigoldi non è finita qui perché
prima di favi gtv il sottoscritto con i
capelli discutibili aveva un canale che
lory 60 56 canale proprio al colino in
bocca guarda nel 2001 2010 aveva aperto
sta roba e io non vi può allora devo
parlarvi di questa cosa per
e importante nonché la situazione di
capelli sia migliorata di tanto però un
po sì io su questo canale avevo dei
video tanti video alcuni che non potete
neanche immaginare ve lo giuro su quello
che volete ballava la tectonic ok questi
video cancellati in un momento di pazzia
tipo nel 2000 e 2012 2013 o cancellati
deficiente pagherei oro per avere di
nuovo con i video sarebbe veramente
fantastico
non credo che questo sito sia in grado
di recuperare i video ma almeno quello
che era il look del mio canale
forse sì vediamo cosa riusciamo a
beccare allora 16 novembre del 2010
otto anni fa avevo matematica 15 anni
avevo 15 anni
questo è il momento più indietro che
riesco a beccare del mio stare su
youtube
non so cosa vedo proverò a commentarli
quello che vedrò io vi voglio far sapere
solo che è un bene che voi non vediate
condividere già solo al logo di youtube
è fantastico freddo 1
e allora il momento 2010 è andato a
[ __ ] prendono del 2011 nel 2011 7
aprile al mio compleanno rai fa mio
regalo di compleanno datato 7 anni e
fammi vedere il mio canale di una volta
ti prego se l'ha caricato lo ha caricato
non ci credo signori ero iscritto in un
sacco di canali avevo raggiunto tremila
iscritti cavolo al 3.703 700 nel 2011 e
proprio tanto perché facevo video su
call of duty che facciamo tipo uno al
mese
dove va bè ragazzi sono contentissimo di
aver fatto questo video purtroppo e lo
dico con tutto il cuore i miei vecchi
video non riesco a trovarli più perché
un'altra cancellati ho provato anche a
contattare youtubers trovata che vi
assicuro che avremmo avuto tanto di quel
materiale su cui ridere che mi avevi rea
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
spero che questo tuffo nel passato sia
stato di vostro gradimento anche perché
erano dei tempi lo so però vivere il
presente è importante perché è presente
di oggi sarà il passato di domani e
domani proverete nostalgia per oggi 3
questo mi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa che
se vi piace che volessero iniziare senza
precisi e non ci diamo adesso vedo io
spero di aver fatto un po parte della
vostra infanzia già infanzia dandole ad
all infanzia
ci siamo divertiti tutti
[Musica]